we have been looking at rates of change
applications of calculus to this world
and most recently we've been in pushing
plant trying to think about what were
these three quantities that in the
context of kinematics tells everything
we need to know about how some things
move whether three things not for the
day its displacement velocity
acceleration very good so we understand
each of these things and we have learned
that if you have you don't have to write
this down if you define your
displacement as X although most of the
years is how that is changing with
respect to time and all acceleration is
is how that is changing with respect to
time okay now we are learning about
rates of change and we've been using
differentiation and gradient but it's
sort of long but this kind of just makes
sense to us okay when you have a look at
this graph and if you pick shell and I
got everything that I think I do if you
picture a point on the graph and it's
tangent the grading of that tangent
right um we understand that if you think
about this point let's put the action
point on there if this is a displacement
function right and this is its gradient
it's velocity function right then the
gradient at any point on the
displacement curve is simply this value
down here right that's the velocity
function right so you can see all right
over here
what's the gradient of this place makeup
it's negative of course it's negative
because there's your velocity and right
I miss for right there will be a pretty
close right of course here you're going
to get a tangent which is horizontal it
has a gradient of 0 which corresponds to
a force easier so this is not
we understand this this makes sense how
quickly how state this is rather is how
quickly it - fine but if you know about
differentiation right well we know a lot
more about calculus than just
differentiation this is one half the
picture right logic dictates then I
should therefore not just be able to go
in this direction by differentiating but
if calculus is doing its thing I should
go in this direction by integrating now
that's what we go into you're looking at
today integrating with respect to time
but you need to sort of catch this is a
weed idea you can think about just the
calculus all that just the functions
that you get the differential down you
integrate up you get a constant you
evaluate that with initial conditions or
whatever conditions you happen to have
but there's something unsettling about
this there's something a little bit
weird we understood about derivatives as
gradient because that's that's where we
came from we were having the limiting
behavior of a secret which became a
tangent for integration the idea
intervention came from solving a very
different problem what we try to solve
we're trying to find areas on the Kearns
areas on the cards now if they're for
going climbing up this ladder is
integrating which is finding areas on
the curves that means that an area
underneath the velocity curve for
instance corresponds to corresponds to
what let me show you a picture ok here
is um I didn't do that um here is an
area under the curve okay let me move
over a little bit there's an area
underneath the velocity curve ok now
what does it mean what does it actually
signify
we'll come back to this in a second okay
so for now I need to do some drawing to
understand what's going on
I need a somewhat simple case okay
so what I want you to do is simply
imagine a man he's let's let's get
Forrest Gump okay he's jogging
who's going to Tim Kaiser now okay he's
just going and going and going
he starts from and I'm just gonna
picking a moment he starts 10 equal 24
meters away from home and he just runs
just honoring I run away from his home
ok what is the displacement graph of
course gun
let's gorgeous the UM just the positive
time axes what is the displacement graph
all first comes going to look like okay
because it's constant right the
displacement is just gonna get further
and further and further away can we draw
this I said okay let's stop 20
kilometers away from home because um why
not
he starts at 20 : remember and then he
starts running he's nuts when does the
speed up doesn't slow down
just does his forest comfy keeps on
going okay I said to you that he went
ten kilometers per hour so I could
actually put some points on here right
so I can get a sense of scale if I said
that's 20 that means that's ten so for
example moments the same distance this
30 and 40 where did these correspond to
all the time axis if he's running at 10
kilometers per hour
one hour to get to 30 plumbers wait two
hours she gets a phone call - okay so
here is our time displacement graph okay
I'm using this example because it's very
very simple
let's think about the velocity graph
that goes with this that comes length
for the right well um we'll draw it over
here okay
the velocity graph is very simple let's
draw the same kind of scale again I've
got tired but this time I'm gonna call
this B you could call it DX of the T if
you might say deal zero okay so what do
I know about this policy graph it's it's
a constant right because it doesn't
speed up doesn't slow down he's not
experiencing any acceleration of any
kind
okay so therefore if I try and keep the
same scale this is the velocity graph
yeah it's really really simple now what
I want to do in try to work out what on
earth this integration area business has
to do with this I just want to think
about particular areas under curves for
instance I've got time one one hour two
hours let's put those guys on as well if
for instance I integrated for one to two
underneath the velocity breath right I
would get this area
okay now can I actually write this this
is just an integral integral from one to
two in this case the function I'm
integrating is tenth it's just ten it's
always 1010 with respect to time do you
agree
now I'm gonna integrate this in a second
but I don't actually even be integration
for this this is why I chose such a
simple example what kind of area is this
it it's just a rectangle just a
rectangle what's the what are the
dimensions of this rectangle you've got
a horizontal dimension and you've got a
vertical dimension right so you've got 1
times 10 yes
so you have a number in your head now
let's just verify that what's going to
happen here what's the integral this is
10 T right or you could have taken that
10 out and just have tape it I'm
integrating if you wanted to so this is
going to be 20 minus 10 which sure
enough is that 10 that you were telling
me about the second year now hold on
hold on here's where it becomes
important this 10 what does it
correspond to on our original diagram
when I displacement one yeah okay so
it's the total displacement between when
I was when forest cut was 30 clothes
away from home and 40 Commons so in
other words it's this distance it's this
total displacement that's been
calculated okay